ja das war also der schlagabtausch der
kleinen parteien und wir möchten dass
für sie ein bisschen einordnen und dabei
hilft uns die politikwissenschaftlerin
dorothea neff sie ist professorin in
gießen puls professorin für
politikwissenschaften frau den f wie ist
ihre bilanz dieses schlagabtausches ich
habe gelesen viele gemeinsamkeiten so
bilanzieren es viele experten habe es
nicht gegeben was sagen sie
ja vielen dank für die einladung
ja tatsächlich kann man sich schon erst
mal überlegen ob es sicherlich noch ein
kleine parteien handelt weil die
differenz zwischen den großen und den
kleinen doch merklich geschrumpft ist
sei im vergleich zu früheren
bundestagswahlen und insbesondere die
fdp bei der regierungsbildung eine
zentrale rolle spielen wird also so
klein sind die kleinen parteien
vielleicht gar nichts also sie sind
recht bedeutend es geht
vielleicht für die linke um die existenz
bei dieser bundestagswahl weil es könnte
knapp werden
dass sie überhaupt im bundestag
einziehen kann was vielleicht mal so als
vorbemerkung auf der inhaltlichen ebene
denke ich ist eine solche debatte eine
super gelegenheit für die parteien auch
ein bisschen aus ihren nischen
rauszukommen das würde ich vor allem für
die afg so sehen und für die linke die
doch in der öffentlichen diskussion sehr
eindimensional wahrgenommen werden die
afg mit der migrationspolitik die linke
mit der frage der außenpolitik
insbesondere der nato und diese debatte
bietet diesen parteien die gelegenheit
mal ihre breitere agenda der
öffentlichkeit vorzustellen
jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt die fdp
wird auf jeden fall eine größere rolle
spielen lehnen sie sich da nicht zu weit
aus dem fenster es kann ja auch
rot-rot-grün zum beispiel geben ja es
kann auch rot-rot-grün geben aber auf
jeden fall wie die fdp in den
verhandlungen einbezogen und damit hat
sie nie ein eine reale chance an einer
regierung beteiligt zu werden ob am ende
die linke in eine koalition geht oder
die fdp oder vielleicht keiner der
beiden und wie eine
minderheitenregierung bekommen das
werden wir erst in den nächsten wochen
und monaten erfahren durch diese
verweigerung von jamaica beim letzten
mal ist da christian lindner jetzt in so
einem gewissen zugzwang gekommen dass er
sich eben beim nächsten mal nicht mehr
verweigern kann zum beispiel auch eine
regierung und mit roter beteiligung das
klingt auf jeden fall nach das ist klar
weil dieser satz lieber nicht regieren
als schlecht regierende ist einfach noch
in aller ohren und die fdp muss sehr
vorsichtig verhandeln dass sie den bogen
nicht überspannt weil die lust glaube
ich der fdp wieder mitzuregieren und
auch entscheidende posten in einer neuen
regierung zu besetzen ist sehr groß auf
der anderen seite
markiert die fdp doch auch immer wieder
sehr klar in diesen diskussionen die
grenzen der verhandelbar kite und die
grenze nämlich in erster linie in der
steuerpolitik war sie markiert sehr klar
dass sie nicht bereit ist über
irgendwelche formen von steuererhöhungen
zu verhandeln und das wird eine sehr
harte nuss also die spd hat ganz klare
pläne in diese richtung die steuer für
die gehobenen einkommen die für die
höchsten einkommen zu erhöhen und das
ist eigentlich jetzt schon eine rote
linie die für beide seiten sehr sehr
schwer zu überwinden sein wird wen sehen
sie denn als ersten zusammen passend
sozusagen in vorderster front naja
es ist ja für die parteien sehr
kompliziert zu
verhandeln weil es geht ja auch immer um
die glaubwürdigkeit also wenn wir zum
beispiel die linke anschauen also wir
haben in den letzten wochen sehr viel
darüber diskutiert dass die linke
politische positionen in der
außenpolitik vertritt in der
bündnispolitik vertreten die nicht
zusammen passen die für andere partner
für die spd oder die grünen eine grenze
überschreiten die eben auch nicht
verhandelbar ist und
vor diesem hintergrund ist es einfach
für die parteien sehr sehr schwierig
zusammenzukommen und wenn sie diese
kernthemen ihre aufgeben dann verlieren
die parteien ja auch jeder identität
also wenn die fdp einer steuererhöhung
zustimmen würde dann hat sie ein problem
in bezug auf ihre selbstwahrnehmung in
bezug auf ihre verbindlichkeit gegenüber
den wählerinnen und wählern und
mitgliedern und das gilt für die linke
genauso wenn die linke dazu starke
kompromisse machen würde in sachen nato
und außenpolitik dann geht es ans
eingemachte und die ihre wählerinnen und
wähler würden das als verrat war nie das
klingt nach langen
koalitionsverhandlungen kann man ja
jetzt schon mal vielleicht
prognostizieren frau den nev die
letztendlich wird ja auch wenn auch
nicht direkt an einen kanzler bestimmt
am 26.09
man kann wohl sagen dass es ein mann
werden wird denke ich
was sagen sie zur reihenfolge armin
laschet oder olaf scholz ich meinen
urlaub chance liegt vorne kann sich das
noch ändern
natürlich ist kann sich immer noch was
ändern aber ich halte es für relativ
unwahrscheinlich und an der stelle
könnte man vielleicht auch noch was zur
csu sagen also die csu das hat man ja
jetzt auch in der debatte gespürt ist
eigentlich in dem schwierigen dilemma
weil sie einerseits
ihr eigenes profil erhalten muss und
klar machen muss dass sie
immer noch an dieser legende festhält
dass es eigentlich besser könnte oder
besser gemacht hätte mit ihrem eigenen
kandidaten auf der anderen seite muss
sie loyal sich gegenüber laschet
verhalten und das ist ein unauflösbarer
das dilemma für die csu wenn man die
umfragen anschaut dann sieht man dass in
bayern die csu im moment aber auch zehn
prozentpunkte unter dem
bundestagswahlergebnis liegt das heißt
die csu hat auch für sich alleine
genommen eine krise und das können wir
nicht alles laschet anlasten
also es ist unwahrscheinlich dass herr
laschet das jetzt in dieser kurzen zeit
noch aufholen kann im moment spricht
alles dafür dass
olaf scholz mit der spd das beste
wahlergebnis erzielen wird man kann das
aber auch nicht so richtig als einen
riesigen sieg feiern weil die ergebnisse
sind so oder so nicht wirklich
berauschend
dorothea neff als professorin für
politikwissenschaften in der an die ohne
universität in gießen ganz herzlichen
dank für ihre einschätzung vielen dank